>>Tim Sebastian - Mideast Davos Debate 2009
I think role models are vitally important
at meetings like this and in general in the
Middle East. My issues with role models is
this, I think role models should be not necessarily
the people who are always in the spotlight,
people always in the media, but people who
get things done at a grassroots level. The
people who are helping in refugee camps, people
who work in the hospitals, the people who
are sacrificing their time and their liberty,
often their liberty, to push the envelope,
particularly where free speech is concerned.
And I'd like to see these people honored more
and respected more and more in the spotlight
than they have been in the past. When you
have people at a meeting like this I think
it's also important to realize that you don't
go on every year saying the same things, promising
the same things to people who talking about
changing the world will leave here and you
don't follow through with it. This is the
problem. I'd like to see role models come
here and put into action some of the things
that they talk about at meetings like this.